direction maintenant bruxelles où
s'ouvre aujourd'hui un nouveau conseil
européen les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement de l'ue sont actuellement
réunis à bruxelles depuis 9h30 ce matin
elles ont entamé une première réunion de
travail avec les dirigeants des balkans
on retrouve sur place alix le bourdon
notre correspondant bonjour alix
première réunion pour faire le point sur
leur demande d'adhésion
en effet le but de cette première
réunion avec les dirigeants des balkans
occidentaux et d'envoyer un signal
politique fort à ces pays qui frappent à
la porte de l'union européenne depuis
très longtemps et qui accuse le coup
alors que devrait être accordée cet
après midi à l'ukraine et à la moldavie
le statut le statut de candidat à
l'union européenne en plus l'ukraine va
obtenir ce statut sans même passer par
l'étape préliminaire de la perspective
européenne qui est une étape par
laquelle passent généralement les pays
candidat à l'union européenne d'ailleurs
cette perspective européenne avait été
donné au pays des balkans occidentaux
en 2003 c'est à dire il ya presque vingt
ans dans ce contexte certains dirigeants
européens voudraient donner quelque
chose de tangible à ses dirigeants des
balkans occidentaux la slovénie et la
croatie voudrait par exemple accorder le
statut de candidat à la bosnie qui est
cantonné au statut de candidat potentiel
depuis 20 ans et puis il ya aussi la
finlande 1 qui estime qu'il est crucial
de maintenir la crédibilité de l'union
européenne dans la région et que les
européens doivent tenir leurs promesses
dans la région malgré tout et bien les
dirigeants des balkans occidentaux ne se
font pas trop d'illusions ils savent qu
a priori ils ne repartiront pas de cette
réunion avec un calendrier précis
d'adhésion alix les le sommet s'ouvrira
réellement site en début d'après midi à
13h les 27 qui ça y'est pardon sont
appelés à trancher sur l'adhésion de
l'ukraine à l'union européenne le 10 mai
ce qui a d'ailleurs qualifié la semaine
d' historique
en effet c'est un sommet qui devrait
être très marquant puisque ce statut de
candidat qui devrait être accordée à
l'ukraine et à la moldavie c'est quelque
chose qui était tout à fait inimaginable
il ya encore quelques mois il a fallu
v les réticences de certains pays comme
les pays-bas comme le danemark et qui se
demandent comment intégrer un pays comme
l'ukraine à l'union européenne pays
comme l'ukraine qui compte quand même 44
millions d'habitants le premier ministre
portugais avait également émis des
réserves 1 préférant privilégier l'aide
directe à l'ukraine mais devant la
pression des grands pays européens et
devant une opinion publique favorable
est bien le premier ministre portugais a
fini par céder il y à aussi il faut le
dire dans l'union européenne des pays
qui ont poussé très fort pour cet hoax
octroi du statut de candidat à l'ukraine
il ya bien sûr la pologne la lituanie
mais aussi la hongrie pour une raison
bien spécifique le pays veut protéger sa
minorité en ukraine mais on sait que le
processus d'adhésion est un processus
qui prend beaucoup de temps c'est pour
ça que la france a proposé la création
d'une communauté politique européenne
qui inclura d'ores et déjà l'ukraine et
les pays justement des balkans
occidentaux cette proposition va
également être discuté cet après midi